verify should do a Scottish accent
Junior Henry Jones jr. brave is the
latest Pixar movie and it's the
follow-up to Cars 2 and as a lot of you
may know not my favorite Pixar movie out
there this is a fantasy adventure type
film it stars this young girl named
Merida she is an expert Archer she has
this humongous just flowing locks of red
hair her parents are the king and queen
and she's the rightful princess but she
doesn't want to do all the princess
stuff you know she doesn't want to look
for suitors and she doesn't want to act
all proper and stand up straight she
wants to go out and hunt and fish and
swim and climb she doesn't want to have
anything to do with all the pretty
little things that her mom wants her to
do the movie is set up as this tale
where she is this incredibly good Archer
and she just wants to go out into the
world and prove that she can make it on
her own she doesn't need to her parents
help she doesn't need to do all the
little things that her royal line
expects of her her dad's very silly and
her mom is extremely serious her dad's
actually kind of Awesome he was on my
favorite parts of the movie and then
something happens in the movie that I
did not expect that I will not spoil but
just turns the whole movie on its head
and changes everything
and how much do you like or dislike this
new direction the film takes really
depends on how much you enjoy this movie
and I really enjoyed this movie a lot I
didn't love it like with every core of
my being like the Toy Story films but I
try not to compare movies made by the
same studio oh this wasn't as good as
the last one you know I try not to do
that too much except with cars - well it
was a little unexpected because I was
expecting it to be like some serious
Pixar action adventure movie with this
girl and you know what she actually was
really awesome in this movie I really
liked the character of Merida and I
liked her voice actors Kelly Macdonald
from No Country for Old Men I thought
she did a really nice job her voice
could have been extremely annoying this
intense Scottish accent but I didn't
mind that I actually thought it was kind
of charming mom it's just the bow that
was horrible but I really didn't have a
lot of fun with this movie it looks
beautiful it is a gorgeous looking movie
the animation is some of the best Pixar
has ever produced the 3d is also really
good as you would expect - Pixar movie
one of the things that I really liked
about this movie and this is just
special for me because I'm a huge fan of
The Legend of Zelda games I've been
playing though since I was a
in this movie seems to draw a lot from
the Zelda games I mean it just has that
whole mystical fairy tale-like feel but
the really big thing that actually
reminded me so much of Zelda was these
things called the will-o-wisps they're
these little floaty white things that
appear throughout the force that can
lead you to your fate but they make
these little noises like hey and if you
ever played legend of zelda ocarina of
time you're gonna recognize na be the
ferry that follows him everywhere and
always goes watch oh hey listen
and a lot of aspects of this movie
really reminded me of zelda and in that
way i felt kind of close to it but
movies also directed by a woman and
that's pretty cool because that's rare
nowadays but this is also a story about
female empowerment and kind of
discovering your own way bonding with
your mother and that type of thing and
so it works that a female is behind it
because they can give it that needed
strength that it needs but it's also
pretty freakin awesome to like there are
a lot of good action in this movie now
there are a few problems I have this
movie for one that twist is very jarring
and if you don't go with it you're not
gonna like this movie as much as I did
see I was thinking the film was going in
a certain way and when it didn't at
first that was kind of disappointed with
that but I saw where it was going now
and I started to not mind it that much
there will be people who think this
movie is OK and those people are more
than likely going to be the ones who
didn't like the twist the film takes and
I understand that so my warning to you
really is if you don't like the
direction that the film decides to go
and you probably won't like this movie
as much as I did the villain in the film
is very underdeveloped there really is
not there really isn't a villain so much
in this movie there's a villain he's
there is this bad guy there's a bad guy
there but the movie is more about this
bond between the mother and daughter and
the situation that develops because of
that and the situation they're in is
kind of the antagonist of the movie it
was kind of refreshing actually not to
have like the big brooding Disney
villain that we see in so many of these
movies it was kind of nice I thought the
film was very funny I thought it was
entertaining I really enjoyed this film
it wasn't as good as some other Pixar
movies but nevertheless I enjoyed brave
and I had a good time with it I'm going
to give it a B+ so as I mentioned on my
Rock of Ages review the schmoes no and I
are going to be collaborating to review
the previous six Batman films very first
review the 1989 Batman is going to be on
their channel possibly today or tomorrow
look forward to that hope you enjoy that
collaboration and until next time guys
if you'd like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuff my
dad
[Music]